[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
agenda today is first I'll I'll give you
like an overview or like what kind of
like pipeline this is and like what
problems problems we were having before
with our hive implementation and and why
we like chose parking in the first place
and and our Sparks implementation of
this job and finally we build some
internal tools to help us optimize our
job on spark and to the migration and
finally some take away time I want to
share with you so firstly I will show
you some results that I always like to
brag so several metrics we observed in
doing our migration so firstly like CPU
reservation time this this is not
something like you typically see on like
the like the when the job finish it
prints like some nothing like this job
took how many CPU years or how many a
few days this is a slightly different
metric where this means this much CPU
was a reserved by this job so that no
other jobs can take it while this job is
running so this is actually the metric
that matters by the end of day because
this is the actual hardware resource you
are like burning during this jobs run
and for this metric we have like two
jobs migrated this metric was like three
to five times better from five to spark
and there is another one this is the one
like typically exported and reported by
our by the actual like job saying how
many time how much time we spent in this
job and this is actually a percentage of
like reservation time it's always a lag
percentage this thing CPU time is like I
think five to six times better and also
another one which is like more organic
and also
thing that matters most to like our
human beings and like our engineers and
the one who is operating this pipeline
is the Ligon see where it's from the
time when the job starts to to the time
when the job finishes but this metric is
not like comparing the two like systems
per se because this metric depends
largely on how much resource you
dedicate to this job at a single time
and also random and also how busy this
cluster is when a by the time the job
was running but this is for like
illustration purposes and latency is I
think five times better but the takeaway
is that it went from like 60 to 70 hours
which is like two days three days to
like 10 to 15 hours which is basic from
unmanageable to manageable okay so how
did we do what did we do to like a like
get these results so let's get started
with like the more details of what's
happening behind the scene so firstly we
used to have like a half job which looks
like this this is a slightly simplified
version of it and we have like three
stages in this half job well actually
it's like 100 several hundreds of web
jobs which is compiled into like a big
pipeline where logically it's like three
stages firstly we filter things based on
okay so first we filter things based on
like the criteria we care about this is
a pipeline where we do we build a
ranking index out of like a row features
I don't know if you are like familiar
with this specific problems and so the
idea is we collect all the like ranking
data and then group by the user and
target ID
after grouping the user and target ID we
get a feature set for each user and
target pair so in which there there is
like group provable operation ongoing
and then after this group by operation
we type this output into a transformer
which is like a C++ binary where we
transform this group and result into a
static rock DB file where we serve like
online so the first stage is to filter
and then goof by that's the first first
like two stages and then the final stage
is we do another round of group by to
shard this data set into shards to be
served in our online system so the
problem with this is firstly it's broken
down into like hundreds of smaller jobs
because high was was not able to scale
to this much like data the input size is
like sixty terabytes
that means the highway is going to have
to shuffle like 60 to 100 terabytes of
data like in just one job which wasn't
feasible at that time and this is like
our UI which is like this you can't
actually read this this is you have to
scroll like 12 screens of these to find
like say one of the job failed at some
day you have to find it and you cannot
this is like a very hard to manage and
yeah these are like all the problems we
had like this is the size of this job
forces us to split the having
segmentation to hundreds of small
smaller jobs started by entity ID which
is the user ID in our case and and also
like we have two checkpoints like the
blue boxes here are actual like have
tables where we after each stage we
write the data back to a high paper in
case like this stage fails and we can
retry from a intermediary result
and it runs like very very slow which is
like 60 Plus hours and right so this was
the problem we were having and what can
we do about this so we were considering
like like options at Facebook that's
available to us a spark was one of the
options was starting to be one of the
options like back a year a year and half
ago because firstly like spark was like
we are forming a spark teaming Facebook
were like we are putting out like
several dedicated engineers to work on
spark and work with the open source
community and also like interning hi we
have like our own Fork of hi witches
like in maintenance mode where fixes and
reliability things is being patched onto
it and no dramatic like changes and also
we according to some preliminary testing
we have we typically can get a better
performance with the exact same query
ex-parte is similar to have edging it
can run like the hype ql which is like
the dialect of like hire like sequel
when when you're going to write in hype
and that those test shows we can have a
slightly better performance when we just
run the exact same query and also in
sponsors like more flexible API where in
highways purely have QL and in spark
there's you can choose from like SPARQL
or Scala API or you can mishmash them
like some spark feel and then some Scala
and then go back to spark heal and you
can do arbitrary things combining those
two that may or may not be useful in our
case but we will see later and the the
problem is of course like it's never we
the team was like kind of new and it's
never tested in our company and it's we
don't know how well scales
so then we decided to try this thing and
we don't actually have like freemen
power to do this so we have but we have
this thing called the hex amount at
Facebook where a engineer can spend a
month on every like 18 months to work on
something interesting to work on
something in another team it has to be
something in another team and it can be
something that I mean but it you better
work on something interesting right so I
took the chance of like this hat amount
and started working on this since and
since like spark is like new to me and
also like the rest of Facebook was
purely on hype there's like very few
spark pipelines and this is like the
largest part pipeline back then in
facebook and think one of the top
pipelines in the industry so so firstly
what did we do like to move from pipe to
spark like the most naive approach is we
just run the exact same have curry on
spark as is so yeah so it's still the
same curve and this chart is a little
bit misleading it's like Spencer but
actually this can only succeed is
smaller because as I interpolate this
number to come up with with this graph
like it kind of run on smaller data set
a little bit faster but it fails on the
entire data set problem so far is like
firstly running the exact same query
plan the speed up is not significant due
to like failures because as we go to
like several terabytes of input size
spark just a generates like a lot of
other memory and and the classic
restarting I think firstly because the
worst box in spark on handling shuffle
and spilling and also because we wasn't
having too much experience with
Bart so like we were pushing too hard
and also according to our profiling
running through HDFS is taking most of
the time and you know all these blue
boxes is like taking majority of the
time so now we decided to the lessons we
learn the first way is to use the SPARQL
which is like a slightly different
version of how cool as much as possible
the reason being sparks internally
generates the generates like the cue of
a sequel courage into native code which
is like c++ and also it can avoid a lot
of like virtual function calls when you
use SPARQL like if you do like a plus
one minus ten it's going to just be just
one single like C++ statement instead of
like doing two virtual function calls
during a plus one call and then do a
manager - ten call so you Sparky owe as
much as possible because we try to use
party oil and also Scala and we finally
see like Sparky OS is easier and also
like faster with the same curry and also
we see this too much chip pointing going
on because we provided a chip point is
good in the case where if your job fails
like frequently you do want to have some
checkpoints - in case - that fails and
you want to retry and stuff but in this
case we're like spending most of our
time on chick pointing so then we did in
another trial so we actually tried like
a lot of different approaches and this
is like a I try to simplify this into
like three stages and then we secondly
we will remove this check pointing so as
you see here a check pointing was to
write you a HDFS a location which is
like habitable we change that to be just
writing to local disk which is like
faster just to HDFS others like
replication and everything we actually
3x replication and sometimes just cross
a network so this time we get a slightly
better speed up still with the with like
test set of data we cannot we still can
on the run on the full data set and now
that the problem becomes like these two
things though it's written to local disk
but it's actually a shuffle I'll talk
about like shuffle later but the the
takeaway is like shuffle is a very slow
and expensive process which is worth
moving data the whole data set from a
set of machines to another set of
machines over network and and also there
is still a lot of theories as we push
our like devices to to like several
terabytes so here we seem to see that
firstly we need some like performance
and reliability incrementing spark
otherwise this cannot like work and also
we are thinking but as logically the
group buys we are doing these two stages
are like very simplistic ones and they
share a common prefix like we always
group by user ID so we were thinking can
we remove and shuffle because logically
it just like one group fat so then we
did another round of revamping this
whole business logic into just one giant
stage as you can see the difference here
from three stages to just one actually
two because there is a shuffle in here
but like this the input and output is
like to have tables and then there is
one shuffle regime within this giant
block this time we get a job with just
one shuffle like we have to
like we have to change the career a
little bit to retain the same group by
logic but but just one shuffle and then
the good part of this like with fewer
stages spark can generate more efficient
code like I've set about like whole
stage code generation where the more
complex calculation you have in your
sequel the more like virtual function
cause you have in hype but not in spark
spark is compiled into a single native
function so now the problem is like
firstly it's still having like the other
memory issues and and the scalability
issues and secondly we are having too
many methods which means our members are
just keeping keep submitting the job and
then it's completely completing like
faster than we are submitting jobs that
means it's not that the time when you
submit a job the job like finished
finishes right away like the class rate
is idle but the scheduler seems very
very busy that means like we somehow me
to tune the number of mappers we have we
want to have the mapper too long longer
than our scheduling overhead because
most of the time is like spending
scheduling overhead and we need to tune
this which like it's like a easy thing
to do we were we wasn't sure what's
happening until like we had some like
profiling tools yeah so this is like the
final version of this a job but there's
like still way to go because it's still
running like two times faster I think
but that it's like a very unstable and
we were we have to like do some serious
like working spark to help make this job
stable and efficient and yeah so so
firstly the the thing we notice is like
shuffling is like the easiest to fail
thing in this job I was just like we
have
brush up everybody about what's shuffle
shuffle is this stage were like when you
do a group at you like you charge you'll
I say group ID user ID and okay you in
this case just just user ID when you're
grouping values ID you wanna like so all
the matters the user ID is first is
scattered across other methods scattered
across other files on your storage and
then mapper is scanning through each
file individually and then trying to put
the same user ID on the same reducer as
you see like user ID whines I was
falling to reducers zero and also use at
the 11 reducer 0 and user ID to to
another reducer so this stage were these
red arrows are is actually communicating
over network to transport this data from
Mecca to reducer this is slow firstly
because the mapper need to sort or hash
group by the keys on the left hand and
also reducer needs to do like merge sort
and search over network on the right
hand and any clustering stability
translates used a tree types if say some
ever failed or some ever after finished
like and then it goes into other it goes
like all the memory for some reason then
the reducer because the reducer will
very likely to talk to all the methods
out there in that case the reducer
cannot proceed because maybe like just
one mapper failed this is becoming a
very very painful and very slow process
in our in our job so what we did we
found like one thing
despite like all the memory and stuff
there is one very obvious thing
happening so this is what's happening
what's happened before our optimization
like map has was firstly sorting like in
our case I'm using ID a sorting user ID
and then put the user ID into buckets
where each bucket is for one Y reducer
like in this case yeah so so the first
bucket here is for reduce
zero and then the second bucket here is
for reducer one and then to prepare for
this data transfer transportation so for
each cell partition we prepare for each
reducer we are doing one theta one I
file open and then Y one file close for
each reducer and we like 20k represent
also the number of will technically
reducers and the number of methods that
is like 100 K so totally is multiplying
those two together is the number of file
open closes we do it's like N squared
and then we actually realize that we
don't actually need to do those like
intermediary culture and ovens we just
need to do one open on the very start
and then just one close at the very end
when we are writing to this file so
after this we like we see 50% of
speed-up which is basically basically
going from that and square root you like
em well and also because like shuffle is
not the only thing we do here so this is
one of the fixes we made to open source
thanks to see so in our spark team and
another thing is like we do like
transform transform extensively in our
job and that's like the part of which
also exactly if you fail and I just
talked about like shuffling shuffling
means that you are switching from o from
network on the reducer side and it's
very likely on a large scale cluster the
network can fail and also the mapper can
be like restarting or unresponsive
unresponsive for a short period of time
when such mapper is existent you will
very likely meet a search failure in the
reducer side and in our specific case
when we are doing transform such a
failure was from a sub process of the
sub process of the java process so then
it leads to a crash hallways
before our fix and then the crack
of course the correct way to do this is
to propagate this such failure back to
the executor main thread and which in
this case helped you in this case the
executor means that is able to retry
such page failures and then catch up on
the mapper this I think helped a lot
also a lot with our rabbit and there is
like there is numerous things we did
like here and there like 7% 10% and 30%
speed ups sent to our members in our
spark team after which this job is much
much more reliable than it used to be
and also after these fixes we also need
to tune our like still ongoing things
it's like you we have to to our cluster
and job configuration to make sure like
the the slow things goes away like this
is all happening as we optimize this and
then continue with the profiling some
highlights here is like chapel service
is constantly a bottleneck as we just
spoke and it's really hard to like make
it faster so firstly we have too little
space
in our class er which which sometimes
will likely be chewing your own setup
too because like little bricks sparks
like the sparks like mother company I
would say is as using is probably using
a very different setup than you doing
your own data warehouse for example like
David birth uses SSD while like Facebook
uses spinning disk and also we tune our
memory and they use a much higher memory
limit than like Facebook's machine has
and also always use like G 1 G C which
is like a slightly like 20% in 10%
faster than the default garbage
collection city and also the cluster
configuration is mostly found by the
cluster admin and also for each data
engineer and the
the person who's writing these pipelines
they should be responsible for tuning
the number of Marigny reducers and
number of our hosts and the number of
mappers and reducers per hold this this
is a bit puzzling to start with because
we don't know what are the writing grant
number of mappers and reducers we
ourselves so like after this we built a
tool to help you figure out how much
mapper and reducer you should be needing
like the criteria is basically each
mapper should be running no more than
like 20 minutes and no less than like 2
minutes and also the mapper should be
like processing roughly 2 gigs of data
in reducer same thing and also yes the
number of holes in is just up to the
clatter of yours this is like something
each engineer has to do and some of them
can be automated and some of them are
already automating our setup and and
finally I'm going to talk about some
tools that we feel that super helpful
doing our migration the first thing is I
think like it cannot be more important
the profiling tool all of the
bottlenecks and the reliability things
we spotted has to be firstly verified by
this profiling tool as you can see the
profiling 2 is basically doing Jay
stacks very simple approach doing J sex
on all of our hosts from time to time
and then we aggregate all those J stack
into a essential place just like the
thing like max talked about we have like
central storage for such a stacks and
then we have a bit of visualization
layer on top of this storage in this
case we use the flame chart in case you
are not familiar with this layout of
this graph this graph goes from the
bottom or actually the top of the stack
word the
the very first calling function like
this is like main function and then goes
down to the functions is calling into
and then finally you will see a rough
idea of where you're spending time in
the shop this is what time by the way so
here for example we see we are reading
from HDFS for like six point five
percent of the time this is like HDFS
reading so with this you you you would
likely constantly see like places where
there's a huge block of very slow
functions and it does it makes it's not
doing the thing you're telling spark to
do now you're not doing your group pie
or your calculation or you you are like
user defined function it's just doing
some internal stuff those stuff might be
the place where you want to take a look
at and those are another very dumb thing
we did and also very useful thing we did
is like adding a button to do stress
dump in spark you are because we have
we've always been seeing like like the
executor or the scheduler stack for some
reason and we are constantly doing J
stack several times a day and this is
like a visual jaesik we can navigate in
and it saves time so I think that's what
are what all we did for this migration
and the tool to be able to help like
future generations to do similar things
so some of the takeaways we got from
this is firstly try to use for our
sequel and because firstly it's like of
the best performance in most cases and
also yes and also we did like two or
three coats or chains like so in
facebook you don't have to really write
like Scala which I mean in my opinion
cool language but most people had has a
very high learning curve so we can write
C coli as extent it
pensive sequel and also the migration
candidates will possibly be those jobs
with very high CPU usage and also doing
a lot of shuffle like a large-scale jobs
and you have to have your own profiling
tool spark comes with a profiling tool
which is harder to use than you think
because it's profiling on a single
machine so you don't know the whole
picture but it kind of works if you
don't have anything else but better if
you can you have some time just try with
your own profiling tool so then it helps
you tune the cluster and also it helps
to tune a job configuration and you're
typically migrating from like hype to
spark isn't going to magically just like
work out of the box though it's getting
closer and closer like I was doing this
a year ago and by that time I spent a
month on this amount in half on this and
together with a spark expert like who
actually contributed to spark
open-source community but I think for
now if we want to do this again it's
going to be like maybe just one week or
two so spark is getting better and also
like our Facebook deployment is getting
more like reliable and we've written all
the technical details of what we've done
in this blog post here which you all can
check out yeah
thanks that's my part and any question
anyone Thank You Sergey so we take
questions now we have 5-10 minutes for
questions before the lunch break
hey my name is Sahar I've heard from a
lot of speakers today yesterday in
general about spark is great and also
it's really hard to debug and such a
pain so which is it how can it be both I
think it's all for slit mm I mean the
same thing applies to however I don't
know if anybody here can easily debug a
hive like failure if it's not a like
typical thing you you see like all the
memory those typical things you don't
you do something weird then you are like
very confusing also and I think the
strength of sparking is a long time were
running the same query on spark versus
have is almost always faster yeah so I
think the debugging scene is well I
think there is a constantly regression
on how easy it is to debug spark because
like constantly there is like people
adding more confusing logs and then
people fixing the logs there is like a
constant battle on that front so I think
but the people are aware that this is
something they need to address so like
going for it it should be getting better
yeah debugging give it distributed
system is hard
yeah right follow-up question again so I
totally believe that spark is better
than hive in some ways I mean there are
via the cases it's the other way around
yeah
how do you decide when to use spark
versus using presto oh that's a good
question
so a spark is claimed to be presto is
like purely memories so far and spark is
can use memory alongside disk so it's
like more depth depth event also
typically when the data size goes to
beyond like several terabytes press and
all
when you do shuffle shuffle means that
you have to write things to this to
persist the hash and also transport over
network those things presser cannot do
as long as that data size is at several
terabytes and and do you do group and
and shuttle then press the wrong scale
rights to to his question so you're
saying you use press two for like mostly
point like analysts would use it for
expiratory queries that would be like a
press to use case and then hive is like
uses an ETL tool and maybe also some
like a top processing and maybe have it
wouldn't really use it for expiratory
queries right so what's that you
wouldn't use it for exploratory queries
and correct yeah for because press is
much much more responsive than have have
takes like five minutes to run just like
limit one query like that right so for
your data science I would you say like
one percent of the data is in like used
in press oh and maybe 99% of it is
nineteen run all its that five percent
versus 95% okay because press also are
working towards the model of like map
batch processing but so far it's still
in memory but the scalability is getting
much much better than like a year ago
so it's mostly ad-hoc queries